В школі мені подобалось, тому
що там були мої однокласники.
Все моє шкільне життя – це здебільшого
спогади на перервах, а не в класі.
Я любила школу, тому що там було
багато друзів, і серед вчителів так само.
Мені пощастило – я навчалася в
звичайній першій школі в місті Радивилів.
Великий привіт передаю всім учням.
І я дякую вчителям, тому що
вони вкладали в нас найголовніше –
жагу до навчання і жагу до
пізнання світу, який тебе оточує.
Привіт, я Петро
Чорноморець – вчитель біології,
співавтор демократичної школи “Майбутнє”.
Сьогодні я працюю із вами, а
також із нашими друзями у студії.
– Привіт – … – Бісить,
правда, така штука? – Дуже.
– А тебе бісить, коли так
робиш і руку забираєш?
– Ні (сміється). – Вона при
привітанні цілується. – Ааа, ок.
– Звідки ти знаєш, ти
ж одружений! (сміється)
– А чому ти руку подаєш?
– Рефлекторно якось. Я так звик.
Людина подає руку – і ти подаєш руку.
Не знаю звідки це
пішло, зі стародавніх часів.
– Рефлекс?
– Безумовна дія якась.
– Набута.
– Набута чи ненабута?
– Набута…
– І ненабута. Є набуті
рефлекси і ненабуті.
– А ось це набутий рефлекс?
– Набутий, так.
– Тобто це умовний рефлекс,
який ми розвинули… Окей.
А взагалі які наші дії
рефлекторні, а які нерефлекторні?
– Рефлекторні, я думаю, що дихання.
– Є нервова система симпатична і
парасимпатична, наскільки я пам'ятаю.
– Так, але це не до рефлексів, це інше.
– Так, але дихання – це
ж вегетативна історія.
Воно не контролюється свідомістю.
– То ти не контролюєш своє дихання?
– Можу і контролювати.
– Зробіть вдих.
– Контролюємо, так.
– Але сердечне скорочення
і багато різних речей –
це безконтрольні нервові імпульси.
Вони безконтрольно діють без свідомого.
– І це – рефлексии?
– Мабуть, рефлекси.
– Так, це вегетативні у нас рефлекси.
Добре, а те що ми розмовляємо, це рефлекс?
– Так, це рефлекс.
– Без поняття…
– А що тоді не рефлекс? Ну реально.
– Я думаю, що є маса не рефлексів.
– Те, що ти робиш в
результаті чогось, хоча ні…
– То що таке рефлекс…
– Рефлекс це все чому навчається
наша нервова система, так?
– А чому не навчається також, виходить?
– А як вона не навчається?
Вона ж постійно навчається…
– Але ж дихати ми не навчаємось?
– Давайте так… Рефлексія – від
англійської мови “reflection” – реакція.
Відповідь на щось. Тобто, якщо у нас є
5 органів відчуттів чи 6. Скільки їх там?
– У нас їх набагато більше.
– Не суть. Тобто а наші органи
відчуття постійно щось впливає.
І відповідно наш організм рефлексує,
тобто відповідає на ці подразники.
– Тобто всі наші дії це рефлекси?
– Не знаю.
– Просто частина із них
безумовні, а частина – умовні.
– Насправді воно так і є.
Дивіться, з точки зору теорії Павлова,
наш мозок це якась “коробочка”.
У цієї коробочки є певні сенсори.
Це органи чуттів – рецептори.
На них діють якісь подразники.
А тут у нас є ефектори –
еферентні структури мозку.
– “Еферентні” – це які?
– Аферентні це ті, які
приходять від рецепторів,
а еферентні – це ті,
які дають нам реакцію.
Тож виходить так, що абсолютно всі
наші дії працюють ось таким от чином.
Тобто усі наші дії можна
назвати рефлексом.
В деяких випадках просто у
нас подразник подіяв сьогодні,
а реакція є через 5 років.
Ми розрізняємо різні рефлекси
за тим, якого типу ці подразники,
якого типу реакції, і як ця
“коробочка” ці реакції обробляє.
Із цієї точки зору нас у першу чергу
цікавить з чого ця коробочка складається,
якщо ми говоримо про
центральну нервову систему,
тобто про головний і спинний мозок.
– Жіноча чи чоловіча? – Не важливо.
Про жіночу логіку це все міфи.
– З нервових клітин.
– Так, складаються із нейронів.
Умовно ось так намалюю нейрончик.
А скільки у нас їх приблизно?
– Мільярди.
– А мільярд – це багато?
– Все в нашому світі відносно.
– Насправді приблизно 80 мільярдів
нейронів у нас є в нервовій системі.
А 80 мільярдів – це скільки?
Ми можемо уявити собі?
– Я думаю, що не можемо до кінця уявити.
– Хто там у нас найбагатша людина в світі?
– А якщо навіть про
найбагатшу людину в світі.
От коли ми кажемо, що у людини є
наприклад 20 мільйонів, чи 2 мільярди.
Для нас, по-моєму, це все
одно звучить якось незрозуміло.
– Дуже багато.
– Для нас так, а для людей, які
оперують мільярдами, це фактично…
– Давате спробуємо
уявити як для нас. – Багато.
– Я пропоную зробити це,
наприклад, через секунди.
Ось, наприклад, тисяча секунд – це
багато? Скільки буде тисяча секунд?
– 600 секунд це 10 хвилин, тож
це десь приблизно 15 хвилин.
– Так, 16,6 хвилини.
А мільйон секунд? Просто прикиньте,
рахувати не обов'язково зараз.
– Може, 10 років?
– Ні, мільйон – це приблизно 11 днів.
Але все одно 16,6 хвилин і 11 днів –
це різниця між тисячею і мільйоном.
А мільярд секунд – це
буде приблизно 30 років.
Тобто виходить, що мільярди, порівняно
із тисячею – це дуже великі числа.
А тут 80 мільярдів наших нейронів!
– Круто.
– Це все в мозку чи в усьому тілі?
– Це все у нервовій системі загалом.
В головному мозку трошки менше, не всі
нейрони в головному мозку знаходиться,
але вся нервова система
- це 80 мільярдів нейронів.
Тобто це дуже багато. Що буде, якщо
один такий нейрончик активується?
– Електричний імпульс.
– Він передасть імпульси на інші нейрони.
– А якщо тільки один, може так бути?
– Я думаю, що ні, вони
ж пов'язані між собою
– О! І тут важливо. Перша
штука, яка у вас є в підручнику,
і як на мене не дуже зрозуміла, це те,
що у нас нейрони пов'язані між собою,
і нейрони можуть збуджуватись.
І так виходить, що якщо ми
збуджуємо ось цей нейрон,
то цей має збудитись точно у відповідь.
Але у нервовій системі є ще
така штука, як гальмування.
Тобто інші нейрони можуть
гальмувати одне одного.
– Якщо виходить так, що ось тут цей
нейрон передає імпульс на збудження,
а цей нейрон передає імпульс на
гальмування, то цей може і не відповісти.
А якщо тут підходять синапси
(у вас в підручнику також є:
синапси – це зв'язки між нейронами),
штук 50 чи 150, то виходить
так, що ось цей нейрон
вирішує відповідати чи не
відповідати за сумою подразників.
– Тобто, наприклад, якщо до нього
підходить 150 синапсів, і активовано 30,
то він каже: “Та ні, малувато,
не буду збуджуватись”.
Якщо активується, наприклад, 50 збудників,
то він каже: “О! нормальний
вже сигнал, я також його передам”.
Але якщо активується 50
збудливих сигналів і 10 гальмівних,
то він скаже: “Щось знову непевна
якась ситуація, краще промовчу”.
І так працює цся нервова система.
– Тобто нервова система – це сума
якихось реакцій гальмування і збудження,
які між собою взаємодіють і видають
якісь результати обробки інформації.
– Поясніть, нарешті, нервові клітини
відмирають і не відновлюються?
– Так, відмирають. Відновлюються
поганенько, але можуть.
– А компенсація якась відбувається чи ні?
– Так. Насправді там все дуже
складно і з віком ми втрачаємо нейрони,
але це не обов'язково означає, що ми
втрачаємо когнітивні функції і так далі.
Це залежить і від спадковості, і від
умов життя, і від дуже багатьох факторів.
Тобто можна зберегти.
– Тобто можна тріпати нерви (сміється).
– Ні, ось цього не треба. Стрес
якраз буде вбивати нейрони.
Отже, тут ми розібрали що таке
збудження і що таке гальмування –
це два основних процеси
у нервовій системі.
– Це можна порівняти з
сигналом 1 і 0 в комп’ютері,
як провідник та напівпровідник?
– Саме в цьому і є прикол. Дуже схоже.
Для нейрона це ще називають
(не впевнений, що це написано
у підручнику) “все або нічого”.
Нейрон або дає відповідь, або не дає
відповідь, тобто тут справді йде 1 або 0.
– Другий момент. Ось це
збудження та гальмування
відбувається у різних людей з
різною швидкістю і з різною силою.
І з цього виводять такі три
поняття як: сила нервових процесів,
функціональна рухливість нервових процесів
та врівноваженість нервових процесів.
– Це все залежить від
“коробочки”? Від якості коробочки?
– Якість тільки не в плані,
що вона хороша чи погана,
а від особливостей цієї “коробочки”.
І дійсно, у кожного з нас
є свої власні, властиві нам,
частково генетично закладені,
частково набуті параметри сили,
функціональної рухливості та
збалансованості нервових процесів.
– Тобто це три терміни:
сила, функціональна
рухливість та збалансованість?
– Так. Сила – це про те, що у
нас ті чи інші структури мозку,
тобто шматки нейромережі, які
складені з тисяч або мільйонів нейронів,
окремі частини нашої нервової системи,
здатні стабільно підтримувати якесь
збудження, або якесь гальмування.
Тобто сила нервової
системи – це про стабільність.
Те, що я можу просто
стабільно почати щось робити
і не відволікатись аж
поки не закінчу, наприклад.
Вдається вам чи не дуже?
– Нууу…
– Це щось про посидючість?
– Частково про це, так.
– Що ти можеш взяти і
довести справу до кінця.
– Типу того.
– Такий “скелет” нервової системи, так?
– Дивіться, тут важливо!
Ось ці психофізіологічні показники
чому дуже важкі для розуміння у школі?
Тому що там накладається
додаткових факторів.
Тобто людина може з точки
зору фізіології нервової системи
мати достатню силу нервових
процесів, але якщо вона не вмотивована,
вона все одно не буде сідати і робити.
Або якщо вона не натренована на це,
або якщо це надто
складне завдання і так далі.
– Але, тим не менше, сила нервових
процесів дає більше стабільності у роботі.
Її перевіряють на рівні
чисто фізіологічному.
Є такий тест, він називається
“теппінг-тест” або “дятел”.
Там основна ідея така, що ти сидиш
і просто максимально швидко
довбиш олівцем у папірчик.
У тебе є 6 клітиночок, і ти
у першій 30 секунд довбиш,
потім у другій клітиночці,
потім у третій, і так далі.
І виходить так, що у людей, у
яких слабка нервова система,
вони вже на третій клітиночці
суттєво гірше починають це робити.
Просто вони втомлюються і вже не можуть.
Люди, у яких сильна нервова система,
у них більша стабільність
кількості цих ударів.
І вона реально, як дятел,
півтори хвилини працює.
– Так, ставимо на паузу.
Хоча ні, на паузу не вийде.
– Я думаю, це можна буде окремо
зробити. Так, це було про силу.
Функціональна рухливість –
це наша здатність перемикатись
достатньо швидко і якісно
між різними задачами.
Реагувати на збудники швидше.
Не просто реагувати, а
перемикатись між задачами.
Насправді те, що ми
називаємо “багатозадачністю”,
неможливо для нашої нервової системи.
Наша свідомість здатна виконувати тільки
одну задачу за визначений проміжок часу.
– Але чому жінка може одночасно готувати
їжу, прибирати, слухати щось в ютюбі…
– Це міф, це міф!
– ...а ви чоловіки можете концентруватись
лише на роботі з документами.
– Дивись, коли ти
намагаєшся все це робити,
у тебе частина цієї діяльності
просто на рівні автоматизму.
Це означає, що ти не свідомо
це робиш, а автоматично.
І це означає, що якщо виникне
якась позаштатна ситуація,
у тебе одразу щось валиться. Ну правда ж?
– Ні (сміється).
– Окей. Але насправді воно так. Якщо
людина робить кілька задач одночасно,
то це, скоріш за все, про автоматизм.
Наприклад, із музикою така ж сама історія.
Поки гра на гітарі не стала автоматизмом,
людина не може одночасно грати і співати.
Як тільки гра на гітарі стає автоматизмом,
людина починає співати також.
Коли і спів також стає автоматизмом,
людина може на сцені
ще щось робити додатково,
тому що перші дві задачі
вона вже виконує автоматично.
Але якщо вони не відрепетирувані,
то людина виходить на сцену і
не може це зробити одночасно.
Тобто ми не можемо одночасно
виконувати кілька задач,
які тримаємо у фокусі уваги.
Фокус уваги завжди один.
– Так от, функціональна рухливість –
це про те, що я можу швидко
перемикати фокуси уваги.
І ось це те, що жінки, в середньому...
Дуже важливо! Ось ця вся штука –
жінки-чоловіки – вона дуже неоднозначна.
Тобто найбільш багатозадачний
чоловік буде, скоріш за все,
суттєво багатозадачнішим
за більшість жінок.
Але в середньому, якщо ми уявимо, що
ось це все чоловіки за багатозадачністю,
а ось це все жінки за багатозадачністю,
то вийде, що жінки
трошки більш багатозадачні.
Але, знову ж таки, це не багатозадачність,
це вміння перемикатись
швидко між задачами!
– Але чоловік може бути ось тут,
і в нього буде класна функціональна
рухливість, і він швидко перемикається.
Але будь-яке таке перемикання
забирає багато енергії.
Коли ми намагаємось щось
вирішувати багатозадачно,
це нас дуже сильно виснажує,
тому краще цим не займатись.
– Тобто закінчити спочатку якусь
одну справу, а потім братися за іншу!
– Так, це одна із причин
і вигорання, і втоми.
Якщо ми намагаємось
одночасно сидіти в мобільному,
а тут виконувати домашнє
завдання, а тут ще у мене музика,
то це насправді виносить
мозок набагато сильніше.
Якщо ти навчишся робити фокус,
наприклад, хоча б 15 хвилин на завдання,
а потім інші 15 хвилин – на мобільний,
то це вже буде суттєво
краще й простіше для мозку.
– Розкажу сьогодні синові.
– Він не повірить, скоріш за все.
– Ні, йому 5 років і він
поки-що вірить мамі.
– І це був у нас другий параметр нервової
системи, вищої нервової діяльності.
І третій параметр - це
врівноваженість процесів.
Може бути так, що є люди, у яких
більше домінують процеси збудження,
і це люди активні, але які вибухають.
Можуть бути люди, у яких більше
домінують процеси гальмування,
і це відповідно люди, які досить
спокійно, максимально спокійно реагують
на ті, чи інші ситуації.
І це теж частково залежить і від
вроджених властивостей нервової системи.
– У простонародді це
називають темпераментом, так?
– По-суті те, що ще від Давньої
Греції називали темпераментом,
сучасна фізіологія пояснює
через ці три параметри.
Тобто різне співвідношення
функціональної рухливості,
сили та врівноваженості нервових процесів
дають нам якраз чотири темпераменти.
– І третє?
– Третє – це була врівноваженість.
– Ну і відмінниця...
– А це інший момент. Через одне
заняття ми будемо говорити про пам'ять.
Це нормально – не
запам'ятовувати з першого разу,
особливо якщо великий масив
інформації. Абсолютно нормально.
– Я думаю, що ви з першого перегляду
цього відео 30% лише запам'ятаєте,
і це абсолютно нормально.
Тому якщо вам хтось буде
казати: “фу ти погано вчишся…”, ні!
Просто передивись ще раз, кілька
разів, повідповідай на мої запитання.
От я ставлю запитання на уроці,
а ти спробуй сам для себе
на ці запитання відповідати.
– Тепер ще один момент про розрізнення
вроджених рефлексів та набутих.
Вроджені називаються
безумовні, а набуті – умовні.
Як ви думаєте які є безумовні рефлекси?
– Дихання, кліпання очей.
– Так, по-суті вегетативні
рефлекси. Вони точно всі безумовні.
Кліпання очима, так?
А було таке в дитинстві,
що хтось підходив і так
кулаком... А ти сіпаєшся.
Вибішувало також дуже сильно, так?
А ще такі штуки були, коли тобі
на живіт показують, а самі за носа!
То люди так на рефлексах грають.
– Я вважаю, що будь-які приколи
над іншою людиною це, по-суті,
спосіб легально виконати агресію.
І те, що тебе це бісить,
це абсолютно нормально.
Тому що людина насправді
намагається виконати на тебе агресію так,
щоб не відхопити у відповідь.
– І ще важливий момент! Не зреагувати
на такі речі якраз було б ненормально.
Те, що ти кліпаєш очима, сіпаєшся,
дивишся на живіт - це все нормально!
І те, що тебе це бісить, це теж нормально.
Це якраз наші безумовні
рефлекси реагування на такі ситуації.
– Тож це були наші безумовні
рефлекси, тобто вегетативні рефлекси.
Як воно працює всередині?
Давайте візьмемо найпростіші
безумовні рефлекси.
Наприклад, колінний, коли ти ось
тут так вдариш – і нога піднімається.
Як це працює?
Насправді колінний рефлекс працює
максимально примітивно і просто.
У нас є рецептор у квадрицепсі
стегна. Рецептор – це нервове закінчення.
А тут в даному випадку у спинному мозку
знаходиться нейрон, який це сприймає.
Він передає інформацію
іншому нейрону, вже моторному
і цей моторний нейрон іде у
той самий квадрицепс стегна,
і цьому квадрицепсу стегна
дає команду скорочуватись.
Навіщо нам потрібен цей рефлекс?
– Для розгинання ноги?
– А навіщо? Нам дуже потрібно в житті,
щоб у нас нога ось так розгиналась?
– Це, мабуть, щось від наших
предків, від пращурів, під час еволюції.
– Тобто людині це не потрібно?
– Ні, можливо і потрібно зараз,
але воно зародилося колись давно.
Можливо, під час якихось
полювань чи щось таке.
– Так, він зародився давно і,
мабуть, він ще давніший за людину.
Тобто це було ще у якихось там давніх
ссавців. Але навіщо він нам, людям?
– Саме те що нога розгинається
чи те, що ми реагуємо?
– Те, що працює саме цей рефлекс.
– Як він працює чи те, що він працює?
– Те що він працює і як.
– Те що він працює – це
реакція на зовнішній подразник.
Так само як, наприклад, тебе
хтось обпече і ти забираєш.
Для того, щоб життя
вберегти, для самозбереження.
– Тобто дуже важливо
вберегти життя ось цим рухом?
– Ви питаєте чи потрібен сам факт
рефлексу? – Та ні, для чого він потрібен.
– Чи саме розгинання ноги?
– Саме ось цей рефлекс.
– А! Тоді я не знаю, можу фантазувати.
– Мабуть, це якась
перевірка швидкості реакції.
Я знаю, що у кабінеті
в лікарів це роблять.
– Так, це ми перевіряємо для
того, щоб визначити певні реакції,
але це інша історія.
Але для чого він потрібен
кожному із нас, ось цей рефлекс?
Дивіться, от я встаю.
В цей момент я взагалі думаю
щоб підтримувати тонус м'язів?
– Ні. – Реально взагалі не думаю.
Тобто у мене багато нейронів,
які постійно фіксують чи згинаються,
чи не розгинаються у мене коліна.
І щойно коліна починають трохи згинатись,
вони автоматично підтримують
їх у нормальному стані.
Тобто цей рефлекс потрібен
для того, щоб нормально стояти,
щоб не думати у кожен
момент часу, як я стою.
– Щоб людина була прямоходяча?
– По-суті, так. Це найпростіший рефлекс
і в ньому працює лише два нейрона.
А якщо ми беремо рефлекси,
які трошки складніші,
то там загальна схема приблизно така:
у нас є якась структура, яка сприймає
і обробляє сенсорну інформацію,
є структура, яка відповідає за дію,
тобо якийсь моторний центр
– той, що відповідає за рух,
і в нас є певні інтегративні центри,
які обробляють інформацію
на більш високому рівні.
– Прості рефлекси працюють напряму.
Якщо це безумовний рефлекс,
то у нас збудження сенсорного центру
автоматично збуджує моторний центр
і ми тут отримуємо якусь дію.
Якщо у нас якісь більш складні рефлекси,
ті які стосуються особливо
людської поведінки,
наприклад, соціальної,
то ці рефлекси точно будуть
оброблятись через інтегративні центри.
І далі ми переходимо до такої
штуки як умовний рефлекс.
Як він виробляється?
– 21 день?
– Це звичка, це трошки складніше.
Так, це теж до умовних рефлексів,
але зараз ми візьмемо
найпростіший варіант,
тому що 21 день в рамках
шкільно програми не зможемо взяти.
Беремо простіший варіант. Наприклад,
один варіант – це собачка Павлова,
там де був безумовний подразник – це їжа,
і був ще умовний подразник – це світло.
– У мене рефлекс собаки Павлова,
я не можу їсти в темряві,
я вмикаю собі світло.
– Тож що відбувається у собачки Павлова?
У неї діє безумовний подразник, який
викликає секрецію ферментів у шлунку,
і діє умовний подразник – його
обробляє зовсім інша структура мозку,
яка відповідає за
сприйняття зорової інформації.
А інтегративний центр обробляє все це.
І він дивиться, цей інтегративний
центр, що дія один раз співпала за часом,
другий раз співпала за часом, третій раз…
І вирішує: “А давай я не
буду виконувати дурну роботу
і просто повз себе ось так це все запущу.
Тобто я типу обробляю,
але так, про всяк випадок,
а насправді рефлекс нехай діє
без мене”. І так діють усі рефлекси.
Рефлекс потиснути руку теж про це.
Тобто у мене є безумовний подразник –
це те, що я хочу комунікувати з людиною,
і є умовний подразник –
це те, що мені подають руку.
І я звикаю, що для того,
щоб комунікувати з людиною,
щойно вона мені подає
руку, щоб не посваритись,
щоб людина хотіла зі мною
спілкуватись, я подаю руку у відповідь.
І, знову ж таки, мене звісно бісить,
якщо мені обрізають цю ситуацію.
Отже, ми з вами сьогодні проговорили
про те, що, по-суті, всі наші дії,
абсолютно всю нашу поведінку
можна описати як рефлекси.
Що будь який рефлекс – це “коробочка”,
яка є центральною нервовою системою,
це сенсори, тобто органи чуттів,
і є ті чи інші ефектори,
переважно це буде про рух.
Тобто у нас є сенсори,
“коробочка”, ефектори.
І рефлекс – це рух від подразника до дії.
Ми з вами проговорили про те,
що ця “коробочка” може працювати
дещо по-різному у різних людей.
У когось вона працює стабільніше,
у когось менш стабільно,
у когось швидше перемикається,
у когось – повільніше.
І ми проговорили як
формуються прості рефлекси –
безумовні, і умовні (складні) рефлекси.
З вами був Петро Чорноморець,
викладач біології, співавтор
демократичної школи “Майбутнє”.
Побачимось на наступному уроці.
Насправді я зрозуміла,
що я скучила за навчанням,
і це так цікаво пізнавати світ і себе.
Я колись в школі погано слухала
на фізиці, я прогулювала хімію.
Я любила більше уроки музики,
але біологія для мене
була завжди одкровенням.
І я сьогодні хотіла навіть цьомати
вчителя… Але цього робити не можна!
Тому трималась і слухала уважно.